مره اخرى ينفجر الوضع في اقليم دارفور هذه
المره في شرق منطقه بليله بولايه جنوب
دارفور حيث سقط قتلى وجرحى في اشتباكات
قبليه طيله الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
فرضت السلطات المحليه اثر ذلك حظر للتجول
في المنطقه مسرح الاحداث من الرابعه عصرا
الى الرابعه من صباح اليوم التالي بتوقيت
جرينتش بعض الهدوء الحذر عرفته المدينه
اليوم لكن حده الصدامات خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه دفعت مئات الاسر باتجاه
مخيمات النازحين فرارا من القرى التي شهدت
هجمات الجماعات المسلحه
وذاك ما حدا بالمنسقيه العامه للنازحين
واللاجئين في السودان الى اطلاق نداء عاجل
لفتح ممرات امنه نحو المخيمات
والصراع في اقليم دارفور قصه ممتده في
تاريخ السودان القريب فهو بالاساس صراع
على الموارد تعود جذوره الى عام 2003 بين
القبائل العربيه التي يهنوا الرعيه وتمتاز
بالترحال والقبائل ذات الاصول الافريقيه
المستقره التي تنتهي الزراعه
يتهم النظام السابق باهمال هذا الاقليم
فراغ ما اسهامه الكبير في الدخل القومي
السوداني بثرواته الحيوانيه والزراعيه فان
الحكومات المركزيه كانت تحريمه من مشاريع
التنميه
اندلعت لذلك مواجهه متكرره بين القبائل
التي نحت نحو التسلح من اجل السيطره على
المراعي والاراضي الزراعيه الخصبه وتطور
الوضع الى تشكيل جماعات وحركات مسلحه ينتج
كل منها نهجا يدعم مسالا قبليا وسياسيا
محددا استمر صراع القبائل عقب سقوط الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير حتى وقعت الحركات
المسلحه اتفاق جوبا للسلام مع الحكومه
الانتقاليه في الثالث من اكتوبر عام 2020
لكن اعمال العنف رغم ذلك لم تتوقف وحتى
قوات حفظ السلام الدوليه الافريقيه
يونايتد التي انتشرت في الاقليم من من
2007 بهدف حمايه المدنيين انهى مجلس الامن
الدولي مهامها بنهايه العام 2020